water agua Oh mizu oh whatever you call
it you're dead without it and with
climate change over consumption and an
exploding population our planet is
running dry for the next few weeks aj+
tackles water scarcity in a way you've
never seen before we'll explain water
wars through stop-motion animation
Ethiopia has been building a dam on the
Blue Nile this has Egyptians worried
about their water supply and they've
threatened war because of it will give
you water saving tips from a diet we
invented called aqua nism we ocwen avoid
beef because over 1,800 gallons of water
are needed to produce just one pound of
it the Hamburglar not ocwen and will
break down the bottle water industry
they've spent fortunes on advertising to
convince us that bottled water is the
drink of choice for the sophisticated
and the health-conscious keep your party
and its peak
drink AVR but is bottled water better
than tap but it's not all bad news we'll
also meet with people who are coming up
with creative solutions to their water
problems hi Lissa with the city fresno
water conservation program I gotcha
funny a bison filter yeah you're for
bunny for shotgun dropper carry pune
prio got a gator pani ma se ma a
believer 10 second so stay tuned this
month as a J plus gives you a water
reality check want more on water check
out our running dry playlist